blake shelton named sexiest man alive  [Music]  not anymore the 41 year old country  superstar received the coveted People  magazine title of sexiest man alive on  Tuesday the mag tweeted this smokin hot  cover of the voice coach rockin a blue  denim button-down and a big smile though  he revealed he's proud to be given such  an honor  Blake says he's more excited to show it  off to his bestie and 2013 sexiest man  alive Adam Levine quote I can't wait to  shove this up Adams et spoke with  Blake's girlfriend when Stefani ahead of  the announcement or she gushed over the  possibility I heard that yeah I did hurt  I heard that I was like wow I think  about this that makes me look pretty rad  pretty cool she would be with besides  being alive right now  [Music]  you